good afternoon thank you i think you
should save the applause for our honored
guests but if it's fine i'm happy to
take it too good afternoon I'm pretty
khosla i'm the dean of the college of
engineering at carnegie mellon i'd like
to welcome you all today and I want to
especially welcome the President of
Rwanda his Excellency Paul Kagame Rwanda
is honorable minister of finance John
wrong Wamba and honorable james kimono
whose robe on does ambassador to the
united states they have graciously come
to Pittsburgh to celebrate a historic
partnership between the University and
the government of Rwanda in a landmark
moment in the expansion of global higher
education as you may know Carnegie
Mellon will up will establish and
operate an academic program in Kigali
Rwanda initially offering the master of
science and information technology to be
followed the year after by Master of
Science in electrical and computer
engineering we will also collaborate
with the government to create a new
culture of entrepreneurship thereby
offering an innovation incubator
advanced practical training programs
executive education and a center for
research on mobility called the mobility
Research Center all this is just the
beginning of our hopes and plans to tap
into the immense talent and the energy
of young r abundance who like so many
young people around the world are eager
to pursue serious study in information
and communication technologies this
program addresses an urgent
international priority the world cannot
afford to leave a billion people behind
in Africa without access to education
they need to be part of a global economy
and a global economy that is
increasingly driven by engineering and
technology the aim of our partnership is
to prepare a new generation of
tech-savvy African leaders I believe
that the potential impact this will have
on the future of Rwanda
and East Africa is truly limitless
Carnegie Mellon has been excited and
energized by President Kagame vision for
this new center of excellence for his
people and we are deeply grateful for
his visit to our campus today it is now
my pleasure to introduce to you the 8th
president of Carnegie Mellon dr. Jared L
Cohen who will introduce our
distinguished guests
Thank You Dean khosla and welcome
everyone to this historic occasion at
Carnegie Mellon University ladies and
gentlemen please welcome the President
of the Republic of Rwanda His Excellency
Paul Kagame
Rwanda story is an extraordinary and
compelling one we here in the West when
we hear rolanda think immediately of the
tragic and terrible genocide that
occurred there 17 years ago at that time
many people both inside and outside of
Rwanda wondered how any society could
ever recover from such a violent and
searing upheaval but rwanda has
recovered and is recovering more quickly
and more effectively than anyone could
have predicted in 1994 in the last nine
years the country's economic output in
per capita income have both more than
doubled our winans are living longer and
healthier lives and nearly half of
rwanda children are completing primary
education up from twenty percent just a
few years ago last year the world bank
called rwanda the top business reformer
in the world and just this week the
World Economic Forum named Rwanda one of
the three most competitive economies in
Africa in terms of its physical and
legal infrastructure and the ease of
doing business there clearly this is a
nation on the move and the world is
taking notice a key reason for this
extraordinary success is the leadership
and vision of President Paul Kagame
since becoming president in 2000 pal
Kagame has put in place a wide range of
policies partnerships and strategic
investments to build his nation's
economic strength and multiply its
connections around the world but Rwanda
faces many challenges the country is
landlocked it's relatively small in size
and it has fewer nach
resources than all of its neighbors and
of course its people are still healing
from the events of 17 years ago
President Kagame is leading his country
to a new future by developing his
nation's human capital and especially by
expanding opportunities for those under
25 in Rwanda and throughout East Africa
this is profoundly important in a few
decades twenty percent of the entire
world's young people will be Africans
yet the opportunities available for
young Africans today they get a good
education especially in the STEM
disciplines are very few many bright
young Rwanda ins go overseas for
University in graduate school and many
never return President Kagame is
determined to end this brain drain he's
doing this by creating new educational
opportunities and by fostering a climate
for entrepreneurs to generate new
businesses a new economic growth he
recognizes the building prosperity for
his country and for Africa will depend
on creating a knowledge-based economy
and he has set the very ambitious goal
of completing this transition by 2020
mr. president if you were looking for a
university that shares your vision that
likes to think big and that loves
ambitious goals you've come to the right
place like you we recognize how
information and communications
technologies are vital to prosperity in
the world today and will be even more
important in the future our university
also has wide experience in creating and
sustaining educational programs around
the world one principle we have in every
CMU degree program in a principle that
will be crucial for our wand and
partners inviting us to participate in
this new center is that we maintained
consistently high educational standards
everywhere
every student at Carnegie Mellon in
Rwanda will meet the same admissions and
degree requirements as students do in
pittsburgh and in all of our other
campuses around the world our students
in Kigali will be immersed in practical
and creative problem solving and in
collaborating across disciplines just as
all of our students are here and in our
other campuses and their courses will be
just as focused on real world needs and
capacities and information technology we
expect that we're Wanda in East Africa
will be particularly rich soil in which
these ideas will flourish we hope to see
some of our Kigali students visiting
here in Pittsburgh just as we hope
students from Pittsburgh and other CNU
campuses will collaborate on projects in
Rwanda and one thing I can predict with
complete confidence the complaints
emanating from Kigali about the hard
work and long hours will be just as loud
as they are here in Pittsburgh we at
Carnegie Mellon are looking forward to
whatever wandin students will accomplish
and what they will teach us we are
expecting great things Thank You mr.
president for the confidence you have
shown in Carnegie Mellon we look forward
to being a great partner now it is my
pleasure to invite to the podium the
President of the Republic of Rwanda
president paul kagame
thank you dr. Jay Cohen president of
Koenig Mellon University members of the
board of trustees dr. Pradeep you know
to engineering students faculty
and staff of Koenig melon members of the
Pittsburgh community distinguished that
is and gentlemen thank you dr. Cohen for
your kind introduction it is a great
pleasure to be here with you this
evening and I would like to thank you
for the warmth and hospitality with
which we have been received a sign of
the friendship that was initiated a few
years ago indeed this is an important
occasion for us because the partnership
between can ignore University and the
government of rwanda has matured to see
the start of the new campus in gwanda
serving both our country and the region
I do believe this is evidence of a
changing tide in a global partnership
one that I am happy to personally
associate with we know that despite
decades of partnership between developed
and developing nations the word remains
largely in balanced in terms of
socio-economic problems on the one hand
some nations have overtime acquired the
many skills and technological
capabilities to better the lives of
their people while on the other hand you
have societies that are steer trapped in
poverty and dealing with the most basic
development issues often the quick fix
to this imbalance has been aid flows
from rich nations in many areas this aid
has not been properly used or where a
targeted in actual fact there are no
quick fixes sustained development
requires that nations take ownership of
their own agenda judging their own way
forward and working with those who wish
to support them along this path
countries that possess the skills
and technological know-how required for
rapid socio-economic transformation can
work with those who do not yet have so
that these skills are transferred in a
sustainable and more meaningful man this
not only leads to innovative solutions
for context specific challenges it also
powers growth and facilitates greater
participation in the global economy this
new model of partnership will require a
shift in a global development and
cooperation practice developing nations
including laws in Africa will have to
review how they conduct their business
in so doing the developed countries we
recognize that given the interconnected
nature of our world prosperity is only
true true a significant if it has a
broader reach for this to happen there
must be engagement based on mutual
respect and interests that ultimately
meet everyone's aspirations in terms of
sustainable development rwanda has among
other things established a solid
foundation of scientific and
technological knowledge as a priority
our national development agenda is
focused on investing in our major and
indispensable resource
which is our people hence the need of
transformed transforming our society
into a knowledge-based one it is clear
to us that technology is a critical in
supporting these objectives we have put
in place policies and strategies that
support public and private institutions
both local and foreign to provide a wide
range of skills to our people we have
invested in communications
infrastructure such as high-capacity
broadband networks that connect our
education centres healthcare facilities
and government institutions to each
other and the rest of the world with
these technologies our institutions are
able to tap into a global pool of
knowledge and build innovative
capability distinguished audience they
are friends the partnership we are
witnessing here today testifies to this
timely approach of matching skills with
where they are most needed to address
complex development challenges and
change lives for the better educational
institutions government and industry
need to work together more extensively
to make these partnerships sustainable
and available to as many people in the
developing world as possible I'm glad
that one has been able to partner with
CMU with its proven technological
capabilities and integrated approach to
education and development the CMU campus
in wonder will offer our citizens and
those from the wider region the
opportunity to develop the skills for
innovation and entrepreneurship which
will check our nation's fourth
additionally the advantages of any
country training are most obvious
because it will allow a greater number
of students to afford and access a
higher level skills and knowledge and
the retention of well-trained
professionals where they are needed most
in our developing parts of the world
before I conclude let me thank those
individuals from the side of Carnegie
Mellon University and from outside the
government of Rwanda who have worked so
tirelessly in the past weeks months and
a couple of years to bring this
partnership to this level let me once
again appreciate this collaboration
between institutions of higher learning
government and the private sector
involved in such adventures this is the
way fought to have sustainable
development
and we are happy to be on this journey
with you here present and the entire
community of this university and beyond
I thank you for your kind attention and
look forward to discussing these issues
father with you in the session to follow
thank you very much
thank you your excellency and once again
reminded of how exciting your vision for
the future is and how important this
program is for Carnegie Mellon and for
the people of Rwanda and I think on
behalf of our community out here and on
behalf of a president I can say that we
will not let you down so thank you very
much President Kagame has graciously
agreed to answer a few questions and
since we have time we'll go ahead with
the Q&A period the way it's going to
work is His Excellency prefers that
three questions be asked in tandem at
the same time and then he will answer
all three and then they'll be followed
by three more questions so we'll keep on
doing this until we run out of time
which is about 30 minutes from now so
may I request the first set of three
questions to be presented to His
Excellency
hi my name is dinesh I pen I'm a
mechanical engineering student I was
wondering if President Kagame would tell
us a little bit more about himself like
who influenced him as a child and hauser
vonda grown and developed in his eyes
hello I'm on the dice velez an economics
student at Carnegie Mellon and I was
wondering what your thoughts are on
China's increasing influence and
investment in Africa hello good
afternoon my name is Erna viswas I'm a
senior studying business administration
two summers ago I had the chance to go
to Rwanda and collaborate with some of
the schools in Rwanda and I would like
to ask how do you envision a continued
collaboration between students at CMU
and students at CMU Rwanda
about myself probably this is the most
difficult question but
I have a complicated background born in
Rwanda in 1957 by the way next month is
my that's where my birthday next month
then when I was three and a half years
old my family went into exile in a
neighboring country in Uganda then I
spent their fat areas as refugee while
Uganda with other one DS were exiled we
formed an organization and to fight for
our rights and liberate our country
which we did but over many years from
during the colonial period after one I
went through many tragedies I would not
to go into details cause that would take
a lot of time and then so that's how I
grew up and expected in the struggle and
then you
the tragic situation of 1994 the last
one who witnessed and the worst of them
all they are to be in the genocide in
Rwanda over decades but this one was the
worst lost a million people and so today
we are trying to we have money to put
pieces back together what remained as a
country and we are building on the
Foundation's we have read in the last 17
years so we are now making progress and
there I happen to be there in the middle
of it with the many other wonders trying
to walk together among us Arabs and the
rest of the world to rebuild a nation
building new nation over Wanda which we
are happy today has come to a point
where we can partner with a university
the connector University and I'm happy
to be one among those trying to make
that partnership work for the country so
that lets me it is a lot more but I
cannot say Terfel luck over the time to
probably take more time than we have
today now on the second question of
China how I view it what China is
merging as a power in its own right
probably many people here know its
history more than I do more than I know
then we have seen it
develop influence capabilities or
different kinds including the
technological capabilities that we are
talking about today and many other
strengths that have made it a global
player work 11 of the elements is its
size in terms of population one point
something billion people on point three
or four that's that size itself is a
strength then leads the column LC need
to develop to a level being a number two
in in the world when it comes to
relating with Africa it relates with
Africa more less has the rates with the
rest of the world but it has used its
power 20 has ravaged it in this kind of
relationship now for Africa China
provides some kind of alternative
Africa's related with the other
countries of the world developed
developing countries of the world
and in most cases Africa in my view has
not got to deliver it should be Africa
remains poor African continent conflicts
and disease and all sorts of things and
the problems are twofold in my view one
is Africa itself we need to simply do a
lot more and better than you have been
doing for ourselves and therefore
average the size as I say the size of
Africa now Africa has a population over
Billy only people and in terms of
resources I don't think there's any
continent that is endowed with more
sources than Africa is so we need we
need to make sense of this for our
development the other point I said to
fold the first one was that the second
one is how the rest of the world also
which is far ahead in terms of
development has continued more less to
simply marginalized Africa and take away
the resources and cheaply process them
add value and bring them back to save
them to Africa where the raw materials
came from in the first place and under
and in fact Africa's not being looked at
as a patterner a viable partner a strong
partner with the rest of the world who
can do serious business Africa is josue
looked at as a humanitarian cases a case
to go under
do good sympathize and things like that
but I think this needs to change so
while this is already changing China
comes in and provides an alternative but
you can't have with one country that is
developed you can't have it with the
child and it has resources that it is
unveiling to Africa resources to put in
the kinds of areas of investment that I
important to the growth of the economy
of Africa and the resources that have
been lacking allowance in terms of
developing say infrastructure and so on
so forth so I would yes 0 it and saying
it provides an alternative for Africa to
be able to leverage its diverse
resources to be able to be where we want
to be third question the last one was
certainly appreciated that many students
of Canadian university have visited
Rwanda and have interacted with the
different levels of our society
institutions and we want more of the
students to come and we want to keep
identifying different areas welcome work
together using the skills that amino
view have a litter of you have that this
university do visit our country so we
are just this partnership that we have
strengthened today opens up these
possibilities and opportunities and the
doors for for lambda and students from
this great institution to come and work
with us thank you your excellency and
also professor bruce scrub who's going
to be the president he should contact
him and he'll be happy to make the
connections let's go to the second round
of questions yes sir hi my name is
Brandon Whitman I am a freshman studying
civil and environmental engineering and
engineering in public policy my question
is what role will green technology and
sustainable energy play in Rwanda as you
hope to further expand the country's
economy and infrastructure my name is
appiah who see adam arkin from high
school studying public policy and
management your excellency this question
might be too early to ask but I just
want to find out what do you intend to
do one you retire from politics in 2017
number three hi my name is Amy Viviani
and I'm also a master's in public policy
management student at Heinz college and
a member of the project rwanda team and
my question is what specific steps are
being taken to ensure that basic human
development needs such as youth access
to education and clean water access are
being met in order to sustain such
high-level educational progress
well as i stated technology is probably
ever it is a very significant missing
link between developed and
underdeveloped parts of the world we
have technology then the bridge the gap
can easily be breached between a
development and development so and as
therefore and this applies almost in
every sector of economy or every part of
our lives and when it comes to energy
absolutely energy is key is keef for
business is key for no more life with
his in education health in homes and so
on and so forth its energy and
sustainable energy these days looking at
clean energy and we've been identifying
sources of clean energy which are plenty
in rwanda and in africa and we welcome
the two kinds of resources one the
skills the knowledge know how technology
and financial resources that are also
required to bring this to fruition to
serve the people of our countries
when I retire from politics i think i'm
spoilt for choices to you from which i
can pick one other time but I intended
to do other things probably I haven't
had time to do maybe I may register if
you allow myself with the University
come under study I would love to do that
I had very much allowed to do that oh I
will keep around and still served my
country in partnership with those who
will be taking over from me I think I
can still make a contribution out of the
office I can keep sharing with the
people my experiences that have probably
helped in addressing some of the
problems you have faced together sit
back at home and rest a bit and do
farming and reading and writing memoirs
about things they have experienced so
let's say I'm looking at all these but I
think I want to still make my remaining
part of my life out of the office very
productive and so after 2017
if we four things remain fine then I
should still be in a good shape too to
be a number of things for myself and for
my country it continued served my
country in a different capacity because
even before it was president I was
serving my country so during the time
i'm serving as a present I'm sorry my
country looking at a possibility and it
is there certainly it is life after
being a president is neither served my
country steps to access education and
other things we we created a vision in
our country vision 2020 we are looking
at where we are going to be from 2000
and 2020 and we had a plan and under
strategies to achieve that plan the plan
that entails investing in our people
making sure that our people have good
health and access education and training
and can have skills and knowledge to
grow themselves and grow the economy a
number of other things that we have in
that plan and therefore when you are not
talking about education is very much
what we focus on as the way of investing
in the other resource I was talking
about under fifteen percent of our
budget goes to education it's a big
chunk of it and education and health
take the biggest and then we also invest
in our culture to make sure that we have
food security for our people and all
these definitely are served world by
different other sources like water so we
have plenty of water in our country we
honor need to know how to manage it well
in a combination with other
resources land and water management and
the environment how we deal with the
environment are very key in a
sustainable development that we seek for
ourselves thank you your excellency
let's go to a third set of questions and
I'm taking a little bit of Liberty out
here but I assume your excellence is
okay with me going to a third set of
questions thank you sir please President
Kagame you first just wanted to welcome
you to Pittsburgh I am a native of
Pittsburgh's I'm so proud that you're
here today I'm currently getting my MBA
at the tiber School of Business and so
my question for you I know that the
millennium development goals were a real
landmark achievement and helping to
focus the international community on
certain development priorities and I
know that rwanda has had more success
than a lot of the other countries with
the Millennium Development Goals and so
I was curious in your view what you
think rwanda has done differently and
what some of the other countries could
do to help meet those targets yes sir hi
President Kagame my name is sue diga me
and I'm also a first year MBA student at
pepper I've had the privilege privilege
of visiting rwanda and got to see
firsthand the remarkable change that's
been going on there it was really hard
to tell that a genocide just happened
only 17 years ago and in talking to
people no one could really pinpoint how
the country and people have changed
their mind set so my question is how
have you led were wanted to accomplish
so much and change the country's mindset
and more importantly how do you ensure
that these changes are sustainable after
you leave office yes ma'am hi I'm
Jennifer drogi I'm a doctoral student at
the University of Pittsburgh and I'd
also like to thank you very much
are coming and I feel honored as well
that you came to it's Greek my question
is with the remarkable economic growth
taking place right now in Rwanda it
seems that growth could be multiplied
and further carried out in neighboring
East African countries if more economic
and technological collaboration were
able to take place in the region how are
you and your government currently
working and planning to work in the
future to make such collaboration happen
or MDGs similarity in the three
questions for the imagery geez what
we've done differently not so much
differently I think it's just maybe
doing or trying always focusing on
trying to do the right thing that we all
know in some cases people not to bring
what they know they should be doing it's
very move that I care everyone here that
I think for the success of our countries
in meeting the Millennium Development
Goals so other development needs
what he needs to be done is Korea we
discussed we've discussed it for years
we've talked about it I think the
difference lies in just being able to do
it and I'm doing it right in other cases
people know in some places in some cases
people know what to do they just don't
do it and this is not there is no
miracle here there is no other invasion
or honestly I'm just so there is nothing
that is so special so different between
us and others well maybe things have not
worked it's just because maybe we've
learned lessons from a tragedy we've run
to the hardware and we somehow the the
dark cloud came with a silver lining on
it where we emerged as better people as
people who now having been hurt so badly
having sunk so low maybe the only place
to go is now up and we started
confronting the realities of Austrian
head-on and just making some progress
being able to move on and so we've
invested we don't have somebody area
pointed out we don't have so much in
terms of Natural Resources talked about
but at least we've been able to organize
and ourselves and make the right choices
put in place the policies that will
serve us
and optimized on the resources that we
have by deploying them properly and with
a sense of accountability that we need
to get the value for every dollar we
spend and especially that coming out to
benefit our people it has been our
mainly focus focus on these almost to a
fault and we have seen some progress we
are not yet where we want to be but
we've seen a good progress and want to
make more progress so really the
difference is just being able to do what
you know you need to do and striving to
do it right and holding ourselves
accountable and making sure that we keep
moving on and that's how we are going to
me to the MDGs that is the experience as
we see it by 2015 the mindset this is
another challenging issue now creative
people on Taylor sins with land lessons
from our history and we decided to keep
challenging ourselves we discuss at
every level in the country we talk to
our citizens they talk to us they asked
questions we ask questions we and some
of the questions are like for example we
ask ourselves why do this that happened
to us
to us this that happened to us in terms
of genocide they did no political
divisions that were there that made
people hate each other and you see why
what was in it for all of us I Rani
destruction that we have witness so
can't we change our lives can't we there
is nobody that would undo and we debate
we talk about it we say there is nobody
else that we come and no up lift us from
this and then I ran starting with
ourselves and maybe the others can help
they can lean and hungry they can give
support but they cannot substitute us in
terms of being able to do things
ourselves on taking ourselves for so it
is something we've discussed and talked
about and said we this is not what we go
to 1994 is not anything anybody deserves
under one is no exception we didn't know
to deserve this kind of thing so we need
to quickly change our lives and that's
how we have steadily and progressively
change our thinking through the bad
experience but through also facing it
frankly and honestly and looking in the
eyes of the reality and ourselves and
each other and being saying we need to
change our lives we need to do it and
then we go ahead and do it so now we've
seen it we've seen the progress after
progress every year that has passed we
want to keep making progress and the
bigger question which you raised in this
is ensuring sustainability this is a
very important question we try to think
about it in terms of building
institutions
so that the cistern sustainability of
progress and other things we've done in
Rwanda do not depend on any individual
they do not depend on the president they
do not depend on the minister or some
other individual but rather on the
institutions that we can't leave behind
and they thinking we can leave behind
when our time comes to leave the stage
and then have continuity in terms of
progress and solving our people this is
what we kind of humanity do we try to do
it whether there will be another madness
brought in by somebody else and soon to
kill these institutions and Dana later
on result into the deaths of the people
we had as we saw it many as ago is
something we want to prevent and never
have again so this is always at the back
of our minds to say it's individually do
our best this spirit institutions let's
think about sustainability of the
progress that we are making this is what
we try to do and for in stafford county
community we have one east african
community that has five countries Kenya
Uganda Tanzania Burundi Rwanda which has
a population of about 130 million people
we've tried to work for integration of
these countries after all these are
people that have a lot in common and I
think we all benefit if we come together
in this form of integration and we've
done it by having a customs union
working on the common market making East
Africa a common market for all of us and
then having possibly one currency that
serves the whole Union and then with a
possibility of a political Federation
there is a road map based on these four
stages and we are walking stage by stage
making sure that we avoid the mistakes
that would reverse the process so that
every step we take benefits the economy
of every part in a state and east
african community as a whole thank you
your excellency one of my tasks is to
keep his excellency on time and make
sure he goes to his next appointment
with that said I failed my task by 30
seconds I think I'll get an a-minus
please join me once again in thanking
his Excellency President Reagan
you